bene a tutti i ragazzi e benvenute
questo nuovo video siamo sul pop up e da
un po che sto giocando horror con di
meno veramente pessimi che però in
genere il gioco è molto meglio quando
gioca mediano no secondo me stavolta non
ci siamo bergamo ciao a tutti ragazzi
abbiamo falsi market va bene che un po
l'esselunga degli horror ecco questo
clima
20 allora va bene porca vacca si
ritrovano e devo trovare la macchina nel
parcheggio perché sono andato a
supermercato contrario la politica plus
time il parking fine c'è il 30 ottobre
2020 kaz 6 un po ritardo
prefetti check dei ticket ceca il ticket
automobile gestito solo quello italiano
chi h 9 hai detto che devo capire quello
che dice lui è già difficile perché devo
arrivare al h
e vabbè la madonna
merda
sì e lo ha detto anche lui
ho scelto la giusta prestito che si ma
mi chiama che voi sector hanno preso per
per questo tizio per l c'è chi of york
arthur del fond
eccola la che la macchina in sala arrivo
apple si usa ok arrivo arrivo arrivo
fila però è un telefono che fa veramente
una luce di di merda cioè come fai a far
così poca luce porca vacca comunque h 9
h 9 stata di quasi perfetto giusto che
noi check my car non la cerca più
perfetto
no no no no mi sono tolto sul campo
piazza abbiamo rischiato porca vacca
allora pazzo maniaco ma questi sanno
guida io poi ci ho messo sette anni per
prender patente è questo qua guarda come
guida porco demonio chilometro e mezzo
sta di qua comunque non puoi fare
benissimo che non può fare due cose
porca [ __ ] ma chi cazzo sei ore
ho paura del buio va bene ti do la mano
io
guarda dietro di te dietro di me
non ci sono dietro i medici cazzate odio
grazie sta andando
bene
mi sono pagato per niente ma non c'è
una [ __ ]
un fallo su cavallo scala la macchina
sinistra corri
si è fermata prima o poi cosa che questo
non corre questa la massima velocità che
certo tizio non tira mai fuori le chiavi
per cercare dove la macchina non c'è mai
per una volta che non torna tirarle
fuori che c'era un infarto imminente la
tirate fuori a tutto aprile f a b c d e
f g h sono quasi arrivati ragazzi
[Musica]
mi sembra un po eccessivo per essere nel
parcheggio dell'esselunga mi sembra un
po eccessivo
però non ci lasciamo intimorire ch siamo
arrivati all'attenzione
h devo andare due macchine a sinistra
anche 8
no no mi minimi rifiuto mi rifiuto
fratello
non ci possono andare cioè sandra
mondragone nel parcheggio è veramente un
po too much di non permettere un drago
nel parcheggio poi vabbè ognuno fa cup
si vuole però sembra un po troppo
tutto questo per arrivare alla macchina
e un'ora che cammino due ore per
arrivare alla macchina c'è una roba mai
vista prima ma poi solo io so non so
perché c'è nessuno deve prendere la
macchina nessuno ce lo può ce lo fa la
macchina cielo qua e mi cazzo e lì è un
metro che poi mi cambi i cosi
ti prego non cambiare ti prego l'ho
cambiato perché l'ho cambiato a casette
a casette stalla vediamo che macchina
c'hai tra l'altro ciò davanti la gara
cielo
e quel porco del demonio
h 8 no
penso che il chorus e non so sento che
corre
dopo che gli sottrai persone che ti
corrono in faccia bambina ed è ancora
paia nuovo dopo come se fosse un posto
normale quello mi fa ridere
una [ __ ]
[Musica]
io veramente questi giochi merda non li
voglio più giocare ok è e basta basta
basta basta basta jacob a si è salvata
la registrazione è uscito è uscito dal
gioco da solo giro ma io posso fare
stavi un ragno rosso come la mia testa
sulla macchina o anche di più penso cioè
un cavallo
ragazzi veramente non sapete mi dà
fastidio
sorridi nomi dare ti ammazzo ti ammazzo
no devi stare di calmarti cioè
mi far incazzare
di nobile quella macchina sta qua dietro
eccola non solo è arrivato così vicino
cioè la si faceva così ciro ma non da
questo lato attenzione
attenzione di sette
perché anzi dato veramente tantissimo mi
sono alzato prima
di comete
e l'acqua prima era qua davanti
ormai lo guardo neanche più dove sta
andando a fondo
clik
clik clik clik clik devo andare i costi
di normali qua però la tensione
nonostante la macchina sia vi provi a
vedere
a casette h 8
o attenzione pazzesco
ma
ragazzi a canove equa è qui non ne ho
cambiate adesso dai siamo qua
attenzione
la macchina e questa è questa è questa
yes l'ha già fatta ce l'ho fatto fu sei
anni l'ho trovata
macchina
era no io e non è non sono morto mi sono
[ __ ]
ma non è vero mi sono fissato davanti al
cofano
tipi dal tema l'anno sono morto mi sono
ricandidato la mattina ero vivo bioware
of parking zheng cosa mi stai trovando
vp per il culo non sei neanche buono
perché mi ero pure salva io vero salto
avete visto tutti mi hanno salvato è
giovanni quotidiani quali ero andato
dietro la macchina quello non mi aveva
neanche preso quindi figurati manco sei
riuscito o vince per me ho vinto non ne
voglio sapere ho vinto questo gioco
ragazzi non usate dire che non ho vinto
e mi sono fatto un culo così ha previsto
è piaciuto ragazzi quasi a signorini
giorno questo è un mi piace anche maris
cosa che come noi prescrizione se non
solo rischiate viene come sempre
incidiamo hanno proseguito e ragazzi
[Musica]